my next bit of kit not necessarily going
to be that obvious
but it's a phone i had a very well-known
hollywood celebrity that was single so
it was very handy to give him one of
these
with a pay-as-you-go sim which made his
life a lot easier if he was giving out
his numbers
to new friends
[Music]
the types of threats that i've had to
deal with have been
so far-reaching and
varied from individuals that have had
grief business partners those that have
upset
organized crime stalkers or fixated
persons
through to terrorists depending on where
you are in the world will depend on
whether you're going to be armed or not
i've been in ambushes with local bandits
in places like iraq and in africa
where there's been exchanges of gunfire
i'm still here
i don't have any holes so we can guess
what happened to the other guys
if you're having to start producing
firearms in a situation
something's gone very badly wrong in the
planning the close protection is
probably 99
boredom one percent excitement you need
to be able to react
very quickly in that one percent and
turn from the nice guy
to the warrior in a nanosecond
one of the first things that i would
always suggest that you have
is a pen every good operator has a pen
and a tactical pen
is doubling up on that option a tactical
pen being a steel pen
which allows you to break glass uh maybe
to an emergency escape
a vehicle i'll leave the rest your
imagination what you can do with the
steel pen
but very handy for making notes my next
bit of kit
a tactical torch if you are coming out
of a situation
or a building with a celebrity where
there is some very intrusive paparazzi
the strobe on this is especially good
because what that will do
is blind your assailants very very
quickly
a personal attack alarm amazing how many
guys will turn around and say
ah don't really need a personal attack
alarm it's not surely for the ladies
well chaps you're limiting your thinking
these can also act as fantastic
intrusion detection
let's say you're protecting a principal
in a particular venue
you can't control one particular door or
no one can find the key to lock it
fix this to one side fix this to the
other side if someone opens the door
the pin comes out and you've got an
intrusion alarm
my next bit of kit not necessarily going
to be that obvious
but it's a phone i had a very well known
hollywood celebrity
that was single so it was very handy to
give him one of these
with a pay-as-you-go sim uh which made
his life a lot easier
if he was giving out his numbers to new
friends
one of the core skills that you need to
have in this game
is instinct and intuition
and it's our instinct and listening to
it and reacting to it which is critical
not just in this job but generally in
our lives
and it's one of the fundamental elements
we have as human beings that protected
us way back in the days
when we used to live in caves and fight
saber-toothed tigers
you could be picking up on a behavior a
face in a crowd
someone who's walked into a room someone
who's turned up at a venue
that gives you that feeling and enough
for you with your spidey senses
to just go i just going to keep half an
eye on that person
when you're with your principal you want
your responsibility is to keep them
alive
uh even if it is at without wishing
sound mana dramatic but
that's what we get paid for uh at the
expense of your own
and i remember one particular very very
well known international celebrity
that i was taking through an arena and
this huge woman
grabbed them in a bear hug and this poor
guy he was held in there
and for me as a close protection officer
i wasn't comfortable with the situation
anyway
but then trying to extricate him from
this giant
was uh was a heck of a job because
you've got to bear in mind there's
always going to be cameras
uh whether that be the press or just
people with their phones
then they're going to record absolutely
everything and there's me battering
someone to get my principal out
only if it was life or death and i could
fully justify it other than that you've
got to be as discreet
and gentle as possible anybody who comes
into this business needs to
learn how to be a chameleon in many ways
with a corporate executive you want to
present yourself
much like one of their assistants or
associates or colleagues not as their
protection officer
one of the techniques that i've always
used is where principal doesn't want you
to be
too close to them was i turned to this
very very well-known industrialist who
turned round me and said
look will i don't want you too close and
i said real simple boss
you have your fingers you put them
together when you're talking to people
if i'm too close to you draw your hands
apart
as you're talking i'll be watching and
that means i'm too close
if you feel i'm too far away however
bring your fingers together
and he loved it and i've used it ever
since
i have to care about my principle if i'm
going to be
working every hour around the clock if
i'm going to be putting
my life at risk i've got to care about
that principle
but i've got to care about the role that
i'm doing rather than necessarily the
individual themselves
but if you don't and you have a
principle that is potentially reckless
and dangerous when it all goes horribly
wrong and there's blood on the wall
you're the guy who's going to get
[Music]
you